[Music]
hey party people welcome to
another special makeup episode of honest
trailer commentaries this time for
the boys i'm a boy and i've got some
boys with me
joe lon how's it going good boys
couple of good boys uh you got taco
behind you on the bed and
which one's okay well it's all good
um today we're talking about the honest
trailer oh and we lost joe
we're talking about already a trailer
for the boys
uh we'll be talking about our thought
process what we really thought about it
uh
some deleted scenes some cut jokes then
we're gonna talk uh respond to some
viewer comments viewer hate mail stuff
like that and then we'll tease you
for next week's honest trailer which is
going to be a good one
um so yeah again i'm joined by one boy
lon harris
happy to be here happy to be a boy and i
gotta say i i actually haven't really
conferred with you on your overall
boys thoughts but this is a fun show i
like it
yes i i mean it's it's like it's it's a
little too much
for me sometimes like i feel like i get
it
it's a very edgy universe it you guys
are just like go for broke
anything for a joke violence constant
craziness and like i feel like every
once a while i'm like
okay a little fart like uh i don't wanna
i don't wanna blow i'm not gonna ruin
anything from season two but there is a
moment
uh pat and oswalt does a guest voice
uh and and it's just like okay i you
know i i get it
it's so much that it's almost like
making the whole show a joke but in
general
yeah i like it i think it's it's got a
lot of depth it's more complex than you
think it's gonna be
when you start watching and i like the
world that they've created yeah i agree
and we won't go into season two spoilers
because i haven't seen it and i'll be
upset
uh joe what do you think uh i like this
show so much that i
uh i cut my own internet just uh
so edgy cut yourself on that edge i i
cut my internet into pieces
it was my last resort hey hey
uh i like this show a lot um i think uh
season one uses the you know the shock
value
and sort of like the the
eighth grader edginess of it all sort of
in service
of um you know what they're sort of
trying to say in their commentary i
think pretty well
i think season two starts to do a much
better job with it uh
to get things a little past um just
wouldn't it be crazy if
superheroes were corporate sellouts you
know or or whatever but i
i really enjoy the show i think um the
performances are what really
carry the show over the top and uh you
know really take it leaps and bounds
above
say like a kick ass or um
or maybe even like snyder's watchman if
you're trying to just really like
think of stuff that's like trying to
talk about superheroes and what it would
really be like man
but you know homelander uh anthony stars
uh anthony stars uh performances
homelander is
just absolutely
bonkers and it blows me away that he
hasn't been nominated for
emmys and all right enough chilling for
your brother okay we get it you guys are
related
a stars have to stick together uh but
and then uh carl urban is so
obnoxiously uh
frustrating and charming charming and
uh yeah new zealand jack sparrow uh is
great
and yeah i adore him yeah i think we've
gotten
our fair share of uh what if superheroes
were bad at this point and
uh uh isn't that cool if they did uh
really
gross sex stuff in your face uh but i
think that the
i correct me if i'm wrong but like i
think this is the best take on
on the corporatization of the superhero
industry which i think makes it
hit as well as it does especially in
this era where
uh superhero franchises are
these enormous corporate money makers
and everything's market tested and
everything's
you know image managed for a demographic
like i haven't quite seen that
real take on superheroes before right i
think we
a lot of the depiction usually is like
what if superheroes were like reality
stars are on the news every night but we
haven't really seen like
what if they got purely commodified like
turned into product
made into tv shows and films and
podcasts and like what if
that dominated celebrity culture which
is a really interesting read and also
strikes me as like
that is probably what would happen like
it's
it's not only an interesting take but it
feels oddly
realistic in a way that some of these
other franchises kind of don't
i think it's also a really smart
adaptation um
because i i think i i've seen
especially like in the comments for this
trailer and stuff people are like oh
if you think that character's edgy on
the show where do you read the comic
and usually they're referring to someone
who's like oh he doesn't just
pee on uh his friends he pees on it he
pees on dead people he'd be like
it's just it's even edgier oh also he
likes kitty porn or also
and so i think it's a really smart
adaptation
where they're not uh and not to
completely shade
the comic the boys but i i think just
like with kick ass they've pulled back
on this adaptation they're like okay
like let's take the feel and the tone
and let's really own in on like what
we're trying to say
yeah there's a layer of abstraction and
distance to a comic that you don't get
when you're watching a real person
uh pee on a dead body if that's if
that's a day
i
it goes beyond just like power corrupts
like the first episode or two you're
like i get what this is throwing down
like
if superheroes were real they'd be so
much more powerful than everybody else
that they become
you know self-serving narcissistic jerks
just because
that they could and that's what happens
to people in positions of power and it
is about that on one level but
it does go deeper and it does start to
look at who the heroes are and how their
cogs and this even larger
system and like many of them have also
been victimized by it at other times
like
it is adding layers onto just the kind
of baseline like
if superheroes were real they'd use
their heat vision to like burn your face
off
don't you dare talk uh bad about the
injustice franchise
uh with that let's watch the oz trailer
for
the boys
a good song
[Music]
amazon studios invites you to enter the
most brutal
harsh unforgiving world since amazon's
warehouses
in the boys
see what the dc universe would look like
if zack snyder never had to take a
studio note
then my grandchildren got incinerated
lamplighter had burnt them alive so
thoroughly there weren't even teeth left
we're super big it doesn't take
psychopath until the justice league
alcoholic the flash is a junkie who's
lost his edge
aquaman is a sexual predator martian
manhunter is a creepy perv
batman is pretty much the same and they
all work for a company with the outward
facing cheerful polish of disney
but the internal money hungry killer
instinct of
also disney sequel after sequel
after sequel
i mean the ironic thing is going to be
uh
well a couple ironic things one that
this is an amazon original and it's like
the most anti-corporate
uh show on tv and then the other is like
with success we're getting a boys season
two and i promise you they're gonna
if this is a hit that they're gonna make
more and more and more
boys things season three is already
green lit it was greenlit before season
two premiered that's true
yeah so the snake has fully eaten its
own tail at this point yeah yeah
yeah i mean like it's making fun of the
fact that these characters have been
commodified but
it is commodifying these characters like
if we don't already have the seven funko
pops like they're on their way
for sure yeah yeah i think there's a
weird there's a
you say that they're on their way like
it takes anything to make a new funko
pop more than like
switching a paint color i mean
it all starts in r d where uh scientists
spend months
coming up with how to get homelanders
epaulettes looking exactly right like
there's a lot more that goes into this
than you look yeah there's a lot that go
you know they've got to think about like
shelf balance for youtube sets and
you know like they there's a lot that
that goes into the
where they place those eye dots chester
funko did not start this company in 1874
to half-ass homelander pop scotch
i want to meet chester funko i think
he's playing with devil sticks he's got
like a jester's hat
he made the first civil war funkos yeah
stonewall jackson funko oh it was good
they were made out of corn husks um
yeah you know the zack snyder thing's
interesting too because like
uh the weird thing to me about snyder is
is he you know he's also loves to plug
commentary into his superhero stuff but
sometimes i'm like i don't know he he's
he's
more just like but that's a good thing
right
instead of being like i don't know this
this show with the zac center never
takes a studio note it it's like
yeah but it i don't think he's aware
whereas the boys is very aware of like
what they're doing
well not to not to derail this into a a
snide off um
but i feel like like his take on
watchmen and in bvs it's like
superheroes if they were real
they would be tempted by evil they would
be feared
they would be uh way more brutal than uh
the
sanitized comics uh presentation of them
uh
which is bad but also awesome
it's a little bit muddled it's like it's
presented as bad but depicted as
epic and awesome so it's like there's a
mismatch between what it's telling you
and what it's showing you for me but
we let's not talk about zack snyder more
than we have to do sorry you figured out
how to
uh vocalize my point which i was making
very badly
whereas he's like it's bad but it's
awesome and the boys
portrays it as bad and
kind of funny awesome but also kind of
funny because awesome is the only way
you can package this without it just
being
oppressively bleak sure
like it's just part yeah yeah i mean we
were it's like
it's sort of like uh like fritz lang
said this about war films too that like
you can't make an
anti-war film that's truly an
anti-warfare because war is like
cool on screen i'm sure he didn't say
cool but like war is fun and exciting
because it's an action scene in a movie
no matter what so even if the movie is
about like
this is bad and war is awful it's still
kind of like getting you excited to
watch it in a movie and i think
superheroes are kind of the same way
like no matter how down on them you are
super powers are awesome and they look
awesome in movies and we can't help but
be like
oh that's cool when we see it
reach all right let's keep watching the
boys wait one more thing i want to say
uh that this really threw me the actress
who we saw in this clip who plays ashley
stillwell's assistant
is also in i'm thinking of ending things
and the whole time i was watching i'm
thinking of ending things
this actress keeps opening up like how
do i know you but i didn't want to like
look it up in the middle of the movie
that's the connection there you go those
movies another good film
yeah yeah oh it's great uh colby minifee
is her name
okay one to watch lon's one to watch
colby menifee
let's keep going step into the adorkable
shoes of huey
he's a pansy who comes from a long proud
line of pansies you don't have the fight
you never have
neither do i who's cultivated the power
to back out of literally
everything i don't want to go to a
second location with you i don't think i
can do this anymore i need to go home no
okay no no i can't cover him no i don't
i don't i can't do this no no no no i
can't do this i can't do this let me out
but huey will go full batman
when they kill off his robin
and join the boys a vigilante group
dedicated to keeping superheroes in line
and by in line we mean dead
featuring this extremely french guy
you don't stir you fall now that's
what makes them spongy this is extremely
hard
uh we can talk about the boys as
characters but i
i don't fully understand who
what what the point of the boys is meant
to be
like they seem to have some sort of
semi-legal
authorization or like somebody kind of
hi does anybody hire them or are they
really just
completely rogue so here's here's how i
see it
yeah um uh
billy butcher not billy business
completely different billy
um uh has his vendetta against
homelander yeah guard that vendetta uh
somehow linked up with and we don't i
don't think we quite know
the history of somehow linked up with
mother's milk who also has
uh a vendetta um against
vaught um i guess that connected them to
frenchie who's just an arms dealer and
they probably needed wet they have like
a
semi cia back yeah yeah weren't they all
brought together by
mallory the older lady and she was the
one i think who had the government
had the government connections and the
idea was to keep superheroes in line
but like what why do they hire a bunch
of random
thugs to to just like
my thoughts crack their knuckles in a
superhero's direction or or are they
really an assassination squad
i i think they're kind of i think my
thought was that like vaught is so
big and probably has so much of the
government bought off that the cia has
to do as much like
off the books yeah it feels a little
it just feels a little suicide squadish
to me of like if superman goes rogue
we're gonna need this
uh a juggalo girl with a baseball bat
call crocodile man
crocodile man's unable then get me an
australian with a boomerang that has a
gopro on it what if they need to climb
oh i've just the guy what if uh what
okay so
uh we're very low on boomerang
australian guys what if we gave you a
new zealander
who has no boomerang yeah no boomerang
um and he'll be backed up by a guy who
works at uh
an off-brand circuit city but he knows
his stuff he knows he really knows his
stuff
if you can get me a japanese woman even
if she doesn't have her sword that traps
the souls of its victims in it
oh you said traps of souls i thought you
said a japanese woman trapped in a cage
and she's the victim i understand okay
okay they look remarkably similar though
sorry we got this invoice real mixed up
um the only other thing else i have to
say on this section
is um a big bit of response we got was
my
least favorite kind of comment on these
which is i can't believe you guys didn't
mention that simon pegg
was the visual basis for huey in the
comic and it's like just because
we know it's just no i didn't know i
didn't know i i
i knew it it's not okay
sometimes facts aren't jokes and so it's
hard to put
facts in a joke video we should just tag
everyone with a series of uh of
just wrote observations um easter eggs
and fun facts
pop-up video during the on australia
edition of the jokes you just learn
little tidbits
do we start a did we start a new video
series called cinema nose
and every time we know something about
the thing there's a ding
and then we say the fact and then move
on i feel like that's most guys
watching a movie with their wife or
girlfriend yeah
you know you know that's uh
mansplained that's her new show
all right let's uh speak of which let's
go back to the boys
this extremely into his girlfriend guy
because if you watch that episode of
downton abbey then
i'm gonna be one behind and we're not
gonna be able to binge watch together
you know i'd much rather be at home
rubbing on them toes baby
i just you're right you're right
this extremely mcguffin girl and this
cockney a-hole
who everyone is extremely unhappy to see
congrats on your promotion soon
what are you doing here i thought we
agreed that you were never going to come
out here
means you brought that 40 000. you owe
me i mean why else would you show your
face around here
oh hell no the [ __ ] do you want you're
like the [ __ ] mold on my laundry room
tiles you scrape it off
comes right back
you know come to think of it no one's
happy to see each other on the show i
guess friendship just isn't edgy enough
don't do it though give the game away
i feel like i hope they address this in
season two or flesh them out because
carl urban aside and even he's a bit of
like a heightened
cartoon character like the boys were the
least interesting part
of this show get
better okay great give me better boys
would be my
better note for season two well one
thing we've been better
it's weird that we never established
like frenchie
and mother's milk's personal like we
give butcher and huey
very personal drives to do this those
two just seem like
they're kind of like mercs for hire and
like they're taking these huge risks
it's so
dangerous it is on some level like
without knowing what they have invested
we're just like why are you
here like why wouldn't you just leave uh
am i i
am not through season 2 i'm really
hoping that that gets more
central yeah yeah and kamiko aka
the female um she
like we said like what what more is
there to say than than mcguffin it's
like we must protect the special girl
who doesn't talk
uh i feel like you see that a lot yeah
yeah i think that that does i've already
that that does get deepened at least a
bit in season two
we get more into herself all right cool
okay
keep going also we're accidental
speak i realized what's that
everything that's mildly european i
think we the three of us think it's
cockney
i realize we're accent deaf is it not
they're all speaking with a copying
accent right everyone in the uh frenchy
french kind of butcher
french cockney one of them french
cockneys
all right great all right good speaking
of
edge prepare for a show that feels like
it was written by these two
he sneaks up on the deep and then boom
press it down
makes a shark bite translucent that
isn't contained
this is something lon brought up but we
didn't work into the trailer at any
point it seems like the seven
and superheroes in general are the only
pop culture
that exists seth rogen we also see seth
rogen and the spice girls were clearly
also famous in this world but yeah like
but that only serves to like underscore
that other pop culture exists but nobody
ever
really talks about it people are
obsessed with the seven
yeah every tv piece of merch every
magazine cover
every tv show it's constantly superhero
and seven and vaught focus there's like
not a lot of room for certainly other
superheroes i mean i guess we're to
assume that like dc and marvel maybe
don't exist
in this universe but like no star wars
like nobody's into pokemon
or whatever like it's just it's just the
seven
i think someone makes a star wars
reference at some point but yeah
everyone's just very vaude obsessed
which it's like i mean also not
too far off the mark i mean like look at
our like look at the difference for us
when we put out a
marvel on his trailer versus e.t
or true i don't know like one you know
like one indication of like what's the
fast and furious like in this world
like maybe translucence in it but also
vin diesel
like something i don't know it's weird
because they even have superheroes
starring
in their own movies right like they
don't even have actors portraying them
right like well citizen starlight is
going to be a movie and yet translucent
had that whole series with seth rogen
apparently
yeah or black noir maybe i'm blanking
which one
the the uh a train's girlfriend
she was in like a cw version or
something like that right
he's in like lower budget uh cop movies
or whatever
you have to be an actor too that's tough
that's tough tough gig
all right let's keep going
that isn't content with just showing how
superheroes would use their powers for
evil
but gives them humanizing backstories in
a cheap ploy for sympathy
like how this disgraced white-collar
criminal has a kid
remember your old man or how this sexual
deviant has a kid
he spends most of his free time with his
son he's got a son or how this mass
murderer
has a kid i'm your father or how this
mass murdering corporate officer
you get the point i hear season two has
a literal nazi join the team
but don't worry i'm sure she wants to
have kids someday but in the darkness
there is starlight the newest hero in
town with the power to cut down the vfx
budget
by blinding the entire screen watch her
follow the girl in her first semester of
college heroes journey
and grow from unbelievably wide-eyed and
naive to woke af agnostic renegade in
the span of two months
i'm done pretending only to find that
her activism can be co-opted
repackaged and sold by the very forces
she was fighting against watch her stand
up
and fight back for all of us citizen
starlight
coming this fall this is why capitalism
remains undefeated y'all
so enjoy season one that's something i
actually really liked uh
a lot was all of the the weird
evangelical stuff
um just coming from where i'm from it's
just like
yes the first thing that would get
co-opted
would be some semi-religious bible belt
superhero
who's like jesus gave me these powers
and and he would just start passing a
collection plate
um so just like the idea of that bible
belt superhero circuit and like what was
capes for christ
and whatever i was just like yeah this
is really really really
spot-on and um yeah her and yeah her arc
in season one is absolutely um
every uh every girl i went to college
with that started college as a member of
the campus crusade for christ and then a
semester and was just like
is there a god man i don't know shot
shots yeah i was sort of hoping it would
be like a little more it feels
it does feel abrupt like by episode
three she's basically like her
transition
to this new mindset is like done and it
is like
it is kind of like inevitable like well
we know that she's gonna the you know
the stars are gonna fall out of her eyes
or whatever but yeah i mean
it it makes sense as a thing that would
happen to that character
yeah i it didn't land as as strongly for
me and i i think lond because
we grew up on uh the godless heathen uh
west west coast so yeah
uh yeah pro bible camp for us uh
oh well but i hear they do better for
school
that's a that's a different superhero
it's like the jewish version of bible
camp
all right let's keep going
so enjoy season one of a show that's
able to address everything from
corporate greed to the metoo movement
with everything from laser babies that
was diabolical
to finger blasting a gill hole oh that
was the worst part in a series that
reveals the unsettling truth of our
superhero obsessed culture
we're not suspending disbelief when we
watch our hero soar we're
this belief that they wouldn't burn us
all to the ground you stayed up
in one of you save martha
[Music]
that is my uh my pet thesis for why
superhero stuff is so popular right now
when we
exist in a world where so many things uh
seem
out of our control and in the hands of
like a few very powerful
you know billionaires or politicians and
stuff like that that
the fantasy is that somebody could have
that much
sway over your life and want to use it
for good
like the way we fawn over like a bill
gates or an elon musk like oh please
save us daddy
like that that is what we're sublimating
when we when we cheer for superman or
spider-man right now
yeah i mean that that is the appeal of
captain america is that he's supposed to
be this ideal draw line in the sand know
you move
like best of us um and i think
a lot more homelander-y and yeah like
batman is
a literal billionaire who's like tony
stark and batman are like the ultimate
ludicrous cartoon fantasy of like what
if one of the wealthiest and most
powerful people
actually did want to use all of their
wealth and power to help everyone else
instead of just like
hoard it like smaug and like sit on top
of it
under a mountain you know like uh yeah
so i mean i think exactly like plays
directly into that the observation that
that none of those people really maybe
want to help us and like what if they
did it probably would change everything
yeah uh explored most thoroughly in the
michael bay film six underground
i recommend everyone check that out
30 seconds at a time or you will puke
yeah also
more gory than the boys somehow i don't
know
why or how but michael bay did it
yeah oh boy yeah you want to see blood
spilling all over a lamborghini while it
destroys precious art and you know oh
that's not my bingo card
like they're not horror movies it's so
weird weird weird choices
all right let's finish the boys starring
new zealand jack sparrow savvy louis ck
what let's go to the couch have a nice
warm pizza roll and wait for this all to
blow over
the i.t cowed american psycho
twilight sparkle adventures in super
babysitting
o.j sprinsen the aaa team
the seventh sense and mentees for season
two
time for a few more i don't think it's
morgan freeman up there right now
by ourselves wait he's mother's milk
that's gotta be a mistake right
shouldn't she be mother's milk
there fixed it for you the year 2020.
i mean just when you think this can't
get any more horrible nah
don't worry get a little more horrible
and exposition news live whenever it's
convenient
if more people were maybe i wouldn't
have to save the day every time
a train versus shockwave the race of the
century
starlight shocking the christian
community social media is still
buzzing about her controversial speech i
believe that our encounter was
consensual
what i want to know who's that dude that
stuck his in her face
she should pop that in oh
okay all super cops
[Music]
you need someone to tease as the big
villain for the second season of your
prestige tv show
you call giancarlo esposito
hell yeah i mean what a great
uh niche for him to fill yeah the big
bad that you tease at the end of your
show
yeah yeah like it's been a few seasons
we need some fresh blood somebody to
make things real scary for the hero
get get me gus spring yeah no yeah
esposito and then like uh stella and
skarsgard just like have their
their niche conquered you know oh man i
can't
he's still perfect for baron harkonnen
and dude what an amazing interesting
joke yes
oh dude oh dude oh dude which i guess uh
not to interrupt this with the news but
there's no way dune is going to happen
this year right
wonder woman it's fine
next year will be better guys just get
through this one we'll see all the good
things in 2021
right wear a mask knock on wood um
20 22 20 22
all right well thank you guys so much
for watching to this point uh please
like and subscribe
if you haven't yet and hit the bell so
you get notifications
uh we do these honest trailer
commentaries usually on tuesdays but
this is a special
double episode because of the holidays
and
you would be remiss if you did not sign
up for our fandom five trivia show next
friday uh september 18th
it's gonna be on disney the the core
disney films
you can win i believe up to 650 dollars
which is a lot of money for knowing
about jiminy cricket or ariel or
whatever uh
there's a link in the description to get
more info and you can sign up
for the phantom 5 and win some cash
that's nice we could all use a little
cash right
yeah yeah um and a little bonding over
knowledge of disney
uh that's what we do every day here um
let's talk
about what we didn't put in this trailer
or as we like to call it deleted scenes
roll that tape
step into the adorkable shoes of huey an
unrealistic betrayal of a guy who works
in an electronics store
but actually knows what he's talking
about
starring
baby huey the flash call me maybe
blunder woman and shut up peg
the beastly boys heroes for hire
the justice league of extraordinary
gentlemen
all right i don't think anything of
value was lost
i do think that would have been a
funnier beat if it was more like yeah
yeah uh all right so there you go i
think we talked about everything we had
to say
but what did you have to say um
sleazy meyer writes this is a good
honest trailer it tells me just a little
about the show
i haven't seen it but it also you know
gets honest
thank you uh we do try to tread that uh
that line and not spoil things um but i
think that they work best if you've seen
the thing we're talking about
right i'm always surprised when people
like a lot of people comment stuff like
that all the time that like they watch
the on this trailer either before the
movie or in lieu of
and like i don't it would seem like
you've missed somebody like i think that
would be
kind of frustrating yeah we don't catch
everything and i understand if it's a
movie that you would never
see like you're watching like i'm never
going to watch ben affleck's daredevil
sure i'll check this out
but if we do a good movie please please
watch the good movie yeah
it's a bit like that podcast how did
this get made like i don't listen to
those episodes until i've seen the movie
they're talking about because i want to
catch all of the
jokes uh christopher colbert writes or
colbert
uh take a choice let's be real and this
is great but he has a tendency to go
edgelord overload these adaptations
figure out how to take an unadaptable ip
and make it available to the masses
yeah i i i agree with that completely
same with milar and
kick ass uh i think the the boys
comic and kick ass just get to the point
where it's just like this isn't
fun this isn't pleasant why am i
reading this like it's just brutal and
sad and just like oh here comes the next
edgy thing like and i think um
uh the boys does a really good job of
cutting to the core
and balancing um you know i know like i
remember with like the first kick-ass
movie a lot of people didn't like the
fact that it
ends on sort of a silly note with like
then he like he like shoots a missile at
like a building and it ends on a big
like kind of silly comic book you start
acting people were like no kick ass is
supposed to be like
brutal but i i feel like they did a good
job of uh
of adapting it and after you know like a
full story of brutal
[ __ ] like your heroes deserve some fun
and they deserve a win
and uh yeah i think boys in this and
that did a good job balancing
all right uh speaking of which adam
holbert asked do you think this and
watchmen
are the peak of deconstructing
superheroes
is this the best deconstruction of a
superhero piece of media you've seen
uh i mean depends on what watchman thing
you're talking about because of the
washington movies
well sure call it the book the the
zack snyder movie or the tv series take
a picture yeah
um i don't know no go ahead
i was gonna say it's so hard to say now
like in 2020 because
this has seeped into mainstream comic
book media like
the marvel movies are sort of
deconstructing superheroes
also at this point like is thor ragnarok
the best deconstruction of superheroes
or end game even
so like i don't know it's kind of hard
to say but i think as a
like an outside property coming in and
sort of commenting on
all of this other stuff like yeah i
would say probably the watchmen tv show
and the boys are like the peak of that
sort of sub genre yeah i think that
there's like waves of like
of deconstruction because watchmen is
deconstructing like
the silver age or whatever age of comic
books uh
and then you know you have batman v
superman and and stuff like they are
deconstructing
the spider-man movies or the early eras
of superhero filmmaking and then
uh thor ragnarok and stuff like that
it's like goofy it's deconstructing the
deadpool it's deconstructing the dark
and gritty uh
wave of super spider verse or something
i mean that isn't that that's what into
the spider
verse is doing too it's like a world
where it's not only about
comic book characters but they're aware
of comic books and comic book characters
and it's like all existing on top of
each other i think there's something to
say about like
what okay so like what are they actually
deconstructing too because like yeah
deadpool deadpool i think
literally deconstructed a superhero
movie superhero landing oh it's time for
the third act we have to do this
you know stuff like that i think the
boys is almost less deconstructing
superheroes and more deconstructing
um our consumption of pop culture and
pop culture worship
and idol worship and stuff like that and
i think season two gets into that
uh more more so but yeah
i i think beyond oh these people are
supposed to be superheroes but
surprise they're a bunch of a-holes
i i think it's more about our response
to them and uh
society's response to them yeah and i
mean like celebrity
culture like a lot of the boys yeah
really just aimed at media
and celebrity and like how we sort of
digest the world
through all of these platforms like i
think yeah it's it's as much about that
as it is about
actual heroes and villains and you know
that yeah
yeah there you go uh so ross tannenbaum
writes
all the people who are giving the boys
one star on amazon since it's being
released weekly
or a bunch of babies sorry you can't
binge it but calm down yeah i didn't
know that was happening but yeah i just
read about that like yesterday
like people are being even though
they're following the same release
schedule as
the first season people are review
bombing because they didn't drop the
whole thing like
amazon never drops i like it better
i think serialization week to week
because you get to have more
it like it lasts longer and you get to
discuss it while it's going
on and it feels like like lovecraft
country i was thinking about this too
like imagine if
hbo had dumped lovecraft country all at
once like we would have talked about it
for a week and a half and it would have
been
over over where it's more enjoyable i
mean i guess it depends on
what else you have going on in your life
but like i can't watch
12 hours of tv in in a day but this is
the perfect balance to me of like okay i
can binge it when the show first comes
out
and watch three hours of the boys and
then piecemeal it
uh as the weeks go on i think that's a
perfect balance i i mean you know
speaking of
uh making fun of how we consume pop
culture
and stuff like that i mean that's a ripe
reaction for a show like this to make
fun of like
you're not giving us the whole show at
once so we're turning on it like
okay yeah it's that's not how you get
nice things
uh ryan's follow-up question what's
exactly that he has what do you think of
the week
weekly weekly release versus everything
at one strategy
uh so there's our response to that here
yeah
i'm a fan i like that yeah so i have a
chance to
watch those first uh few episodes uh
today
in time for uh tonight's episode and i
love that i can catch up
um so i hope you will catch up with the
boys
and with us with every video we've ever
made by the time we come back next
tuesday
with an australian commentary and a new
honest trailer uh last week
the clue i gave was i just said that it
was going to be brave
i'm on the same page now i remember what
it is yeah and now
i'll just say that it's also going to be
true
it's going to be brave and true and
honest
so go lon thank you for being with me
thank you audience like subscribe do the
fandom five and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you